[Musica]
grazie all'invito essere qua buongiorno
grazie a voi siete venuti ad ascoltarci
io condivido un pochino il mio percorso
cioè inizio con con la voglia di
praticamente fare un progetto un
progetto che mi porta si postale di
paesi sono brasiliana sono dell 83 e
seguo il sogno fin da bambina di
disegnare di progettare di fare qualcosa
di nuovo di cui non potevo fare
assolutamente nel mio paese perché
comunque in brasile eravamo molto molto
molto indietro e l'italia era il paese
di cui mi ispirava tantissimo per la
grande eccellenza che c'è è un paese
pieno di storia e questa cosa mi ha
ispirato tantissimo venire qua perché
volevo imparare e per quello dopo la
laurea di industrial design sono venuta
per fare un master di accessori e dopo
di che la grande voglia di fare un
progetto tutto mio no nel 2009 ho
preparato una collezione di cui sapevo
che resta sarebbe molto difficile
fare questo progetto perché avevo 26
anni e comunque nessuna azienda italiana
quando una ragazza a busta la porta e
dice ciao vorrei fare la collezione di
borse vorrei proporre
un'idea nuova
qualcosa comunque non c'è ancora nel
mercato mi accetterebbe e con la
costanza di veramente prendere la
macchina e andare in tutta l'italia dei
poli come industriale come firenze
mara marche venezia cioè fino a dopo il
ritornare a vicino milano ho iniziato il
mio percorso facendo lame linea di borse
nodi cui dopodiché ho avuto grandi
frutti ho avuto un'altra distribuzione e
sono stato inserito nella lista di
business of fashion come dei 500 nomi
creativi e che comunque chi sta facendo
in the fashion industry and
ho detto wow sto facendo qualcosa che
comunque mi porta avanti questa idea sta
facendo delle persone più felice o
magari quando vogliamo comprare qualcosa
che ci volevo coccolare diciamo wow la
mia borsa può soddisfare quello che quel
pensiero
dopodiché
passando gli anni e sviluppando ancora
più l'azienda avendo un team
vicino perché credo che comunque è
importante lavorare in team mi nasce
anche l'idea di
portare questo progetto a qualcun altro
per darmi una mano e da lì entrò a far
parte di un gruppo importante che si
chiama tb di reggio rosso di cui è stata
una partnership strategica per tre anni
di cui sono stati di frutti positivi
frutti negativi e dopo nel dimensionale
riprendo il mio marco indietro
questo marchio è comunque continua a
fare borse scarpe e adesso si passa
velocemente
potete vedere un attimino un po dei
prodotti e cosa fa cosa succede in
questo esatto momento e mi trovo a un un
esempio di
di un progetto che praticamente mi torni
in mano con tutta libertà di poter fare
no con tutta la libertà comunque di
essere
totale e al cento per cento di nuovo su
questo progetto e questo ci vuole anche
grande coraggio perché nella fine quando
si iniziò un percorso e dopo magari con
gli alti bassi no le cose non succedono
in un vano come ci aspettiamo
succede che dobbiamo rimboccarci 29 le
mani e tornare a fare delle finte
assistenti inviare delle e mail ei
giornali in via ai negozi comunque
cercare di proseguire il sogno e per me
questa costanza questo coraggio è sempre
stato presente la mia vita e sono anche
felice di condividere perché tante volte
ci auto sabotiamo pensando che non
possiamo farcela o piuttosto ci
dimentichiamo che
quelli che noi siamo capaci di fare
sappiamo solo noi e quella è una cosa
che nessun altro ti portiamo mai
togliere della vita ce ne sono felice
che la creatività praticamente è dalla
mia parte diciamola così e da lì dal
2019 fino ad oggi continua a fare delle
collaborazioni oltre ai sviluppare per
il mio marchio di cui c'è voluto un coro
di più un po di coraggio questo adesso e
racconterà conto un po dell'essere di
bitossi vita sano è un'eccellenza
italiana sulla ceramica è da tantissimo
tempo è un polo industriale di montelupo
di cui loro fanno a mano praticamente
tutti i singoli pezzi e questo è stato
un progetto fatto per il salone del
mobile del 2019 di cui non tornerei ai
fiori e alle origini della mia
formazione di uso designer dopo
tantissimi anni che non progettavo un
oggetto e dicevo perché non farà dei
fiori chi non appassiscono mai perché
comunque è anche una coccola la ceramica
diventa anche un nuovo accessorio no
e questa gioia di poter creare delle
forme di comunque sono anche dei
contenitori
delle farlo un po anche di fiori mezzi
tropicali ma chi portano gioia casa e
quello che ha girato ancora di più
andare lì a prendere la macchina alzarmi
alle 4 del mattino andare a parlare con
l'artigiano a vedere che
shape la la forma del calco nodi cui
viene fatta a questo fiore non andava
bene e da lì andare avanti indietro fino
a riuscire a presentare questa
collezione personale del mobile e questa
forse di reinventarsi secondo me
dobbiamo
prendercela anche dal niente perché
comunque arriva magari dalla pancia no
perché se il progetto con il progetto
totalmente nuovo e oltre ai studiarlo a
capire chi è cliente come si può
produrre come si può farlo secondo me
solo la passione e anche la voglia di
fare la fame di riuscirci di riuscire a
fare qualcosa di nuovo e comunque
presentare un progetto anche la voglia
di non mollarlo no perché tante volte
iniziare il primo passo può sembrare
molto facile ma persistere per
continuare a fare che quella cosa
succeda è anche molto difficile questo
progetto è stato fatto in piena pandemia
come anche altre due che vedremo subito
dopo sono stati fatti dei tappeti dei
tappeti nutrienti in nepal dove la loro
non ha tecnica che annodano punto per
punto se fosse uno dei piccoli pixel con
tantissimi i fili di lana e seta con una
manualità incredibile e questa cosa da
permettere di fare delle forme di
intarsi e comunque giocare con degli
elementi che utilizzavo anche nella mia
linea di borse è creata farla diventare
totalmente cap e star cup e stabile o
piuttosto anche me sono muro cioè poter
giocare anche con delle forme e anche
con di un prodotto che comunque può
essere
diverso dal solito il tappeto quadrato
infatti per fare tutte queste forme e ne
ho ascoltati in di tante da quelli libro
dicevano perché comunque per fare degli
angolo è stato veramente molto difficile
e con questo gioco di geometria è stata
qualcosa di nuovo e qualcosa anche chi
ha aperto a questo partner che si chiama
julian un'opportunità e anche di
imparare una nuova tecnica
questi sono i dettagli dei colori molto
di zoom e la costanza la costanza quello
che secondo me ci deve muovere cime
promuovere veramente sempre la costanza
di cui di mettermi in gioco non una
partnership perché sono sempre stato
dietro il prodotto con la velina e di
borse e facendo una una collaborazione
con questo brand di schiavo esca rosso
che è un brand tedesco però è totalmente
made in italy mi hanno detto no fai tu
la magia e che ti mettiamo proprio in
prima fila
proprio in
partecipi dello shooting è lì con come
una magia
abbiamo fatto delle scarpe di cui loro
non avevano nemmeno il mercato femminile
come inserimento di prodotto perché
fanno praticamente il uomo con le scarpe
con un mono prodotto con una ballerina
una cinquantina e un padre abbiamo
aumentato il fatturato di più di 100k in
tre mesi perché è un prodotto che
comunque diventa cross aging in classi
molto inclusivo
quello che ci fa veramente
lavorare voler fare bene e vedere qual è
la reazione delle persone quando vedono
una borsa una scarpa un pezzo per la
casa quando acquistiamo qualcosa per noi
che sia usato riciclato nuovo sono anche
di momenti di cui ci gratifichi amo e
per chi li crea è una cosa incredibile
quando sappiamo che quella cosa è andata
a buon fine
chi con la coccola e andata bene e che
qualcuno se lo godrà se lo indosserà e
si sentirà ancora più bella
e questa cosa mi fa molta molta molta
molta gioia
in piena pandemia è arrivata questa
azienda di cui loro sono inglesi si
chiamano super nova con la missione di
fare solo prodotti riciclabili e
riciclati e da questa tecnica e mi ero
chiesto possiamo fare qualcosa abbiamo
questa con questa possibilità è un film
3d e dobbiamo fare qualcosa di diverso
e allora detto va bene lo chiameremo
lara di volta volte in portoghese vuol
dire ritornare allora per me la plastica
che muore orrenda e ritorna pazzesca
pazzesca anche nel modo di utilizzo
fregi comunque creando degli oggetti chi
sono diversi che possono totalmente
versatile e stampati mescola del colore
che può essere un vaso un bene o un
conteiner un
un
poco anche diciamola così diverso è il
tema a un parto telefono a tanti tanti
tanti possibilità di avere una tecnica
nuova facendo un filo totalmente
riciclato e totalmente riciclabile cosa
vuoi dire che
prendo quello pezzo non lo voglio più 10
per cento reciclabili perché non a colla
non ha aggiunto non a chiodi non ha
nulla e questo era una grande cosa
perché è la calzatura e della
pelletteria siamo moltissimo indietro su
questo argomento non solo per la materia
prima ma bensì per la
industrializzazione
qua altri prodotti anche con supernove
di cui vediamo
e questo mi porta a quest'ultimo
progetto
nell'ultimo progetto che è stato
lanciato recentemente otro ieri di cui è
stata una grande sfida lavorare con il
settore della calzetteria perché da
designer di scarpe borse e prodotti
lavorare per la prima volta nel corpo
umano
era una cosa totalmente nuova come si
può lavorare e visualizzare e migliorare
ancora di più una una gamba aggiungendo
un pattern facendo che questa causa
diventi anche un proprio accessorio e
questo produttore che si chiama oro blu
cioè qua in italia è un pionere calze
dell'italiana e dal 1930 che
praticamente fa questo no non è piccolo
e grande mai piccolo perché non è molto
conosciuto però a tutta una catena i una
filiera made in italy no è questa devo
dire che sono stata molto felice delle
collaborazioni che strategicamente
scelto per lavorare come paolano
scegliendo dei produttori che comunque
credono nell eccellenza del prodotto
scegliendo
i fornitori chi comunque pensano che
possono farcela chi fano po in italia
che comunque non è etica
questa è una cosa che non si può dare
per scontato ed erano è un valore molto
bello
altri letti altri lavorazione e questo
gioco con un produttore che sapeva fare
piuttosto era abituato a fare solo
esclusivamente un tipo di prodotto
cercare di lavorare con i colori con
praticamente con il bagno delle tinture
cioè è stato comunque un innovazione
anche per loro per arrivare su un nuovo
metodo anche di di design quello che
praticamente voglio arrivare su su
questa parte un po più brasiliana no
tante volte mi trovo alle persone che mi
chiedono ma se più italiano brasiliana
non saprei dire sono un po mic sono
tutte 2 cioè io credo nella mia gioia
nella galleria che è molto brasiliano è
molto aperta ma anche un po di di rigore
ricco di di costanza di perfezione di
comunque di tanto lavoro e con carter di
cui è stato chiesto una capsula
praticamente di borse scarpe
avevo pensato cosa possiamo fare perché
onestamente no scarpe borse di plastica
hanno fatto tantissimi allora detto
perché non immaginiamo questa donna che
è il suo piano è stato piuttosto no non
è stagione estiva e comunque
la gioia di comunque di uscire di casa
ma andare in spiaggia di mettere i fiori
di mettere i fiori nei piedi però di
avere un attimino anche di rialzo perché
si sta in spiaggia la sabbia un attimino
di altezza ti aiuta anche un po di più
e diciamo è stato progetto molto
divertente in verità è uno dei più
antichi
perché
i tempi del design e il tempi della moda
sono totalmente diversi questo progetto
avevo iniziato praticamente un anno e
mezzo prima di uscire e nella moda
magari qualche volta facciamo anche due
mesi un mese prima che esca
magari no si va bene è l'abbigliamento
anche due giorni prima dalla sfilata e
la scarpa almeno un mesetto 15 giorni ci
vuole diciamo che lì è stata un bel
divertimento
qua
c'è una causa che mi sta molto molto
molto cara che la parte di portare una
bandiera no che portare una bandiera in
alto per tutte le nostre cause però per
primis portare in alto quella che è la
nostra no perché tante volte magari
lavoriamo facciamo tutto quello che ci
viene chiesto però ci dimentichiamo
anche di portarla bandiere per noi
stessi e con questo questo questo
progetto e che è stato la corsa di mike
mike weir anne heche state nel 2015
ci è stato richiesto di sviluppare una
borsa no ho detto perché non facciamo le
donne che vanno è alzato la bandiera di
cui di quello che noi crediamo nella
nostra capacità è di quelle che vogliamo
fare perché comunque purtroppo 1 e delle
difficoltà più grandi di cui io ho
trovato qui in italia è stata una grande
barriera anche perché sono straniere
perché sono donna e perché no anche già
predisposta più però all'epoca è stata
diciamo che anche qua quando una parte
alla bandiera in alto e alla costanza di
credere in quello che vuole fare non c'è
nessuno che ti dirà che non lo puoi
farlo nessuno chi ti toglierà le tue
idee e nessuno che ti dirà non potrai
portarla alla bandiera
e questa questo progetto è stato molto
significativo
le borse sono andati bene tutte le donne
sono andati in corsa milano e speriamo
che ci sia di nuovo prossimamente
un'altra è comunque è stato un
bellissimo progetto io voglio concludere
non sono molto avrà parlare spero che
sia d'estate sono state nei tempi per
dire che è la vita è troppo corta e
perché non dobbiamo provarci perché
dobbiamo insistere su quello che
vogliamo su quale crediamo e comunque
perché non possiamo dare il primo passo
per noi stessi su quello che noi
vogliamo fare nel mio caso ho fatto un
azienda con 26 anni sono andate ad un
gruppo gigantesco nelle sono ripresa il
marchio indietro e sono qua ancora a
divertirmi a lavorare a rifare tutto di
nuovo con più consapevolezza e questo
non c'è il regalo più grande di cui non
portarla mia vendere in alto e alla ri
spero che anche voi portate la vostra
[Musica]
[Applauso]